[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual polític cuando
el comunismo conoció a la madre rusia
apareció en escena una de las
principales superpotencias del siglo 20
la unión soviética
[Música]
siete décadas de existencia resumidas en
una política del partido único planes
quinquenales para la economía la
victoria contra la demana nazi por
supuesto la guerra fría contra el
capitalismo y unos años ochenta para
olvidar con afganistán
chernóbil y la caída del muro de berlín
como símbolos de su derrumbe final el
down
[Aplausos]
de los escombros de la urss la unión de
repúblicas socialistas soviéticas
aparecieron precisamente eso 15
repúblicas independientes
15 repúblicas que la propaganda política
presentó como si fueran algo así como la
modern family'' del siglo 20 pero con
menos comedia hay más martillo
todo para que al final de estas
repúblicas acabarán con más rencillas
entre sí y cuentas pendientes que las
mismísimas familias de juego de tronos
y ahora pues ahí está putin
reivindicando el liderazgo ruso en el
espacio postsoviético con una
organización que pueda mirar de tú a tú
a la unión europea
esta organización tiene nombre la unión
económica euroasiática
y lo primero que queréis saber es quién
demonios pertenece a esta organización
todos los países de la unión soviética
pues para lamento de putin no pero ojo
no porque lo que pretenda sea ni mucho
menos reconstruir exactamente la unión
soviética
amigos la unión soviética ha
desaparecido en la navidad de 1991 pero
os hago una pregunta acaso vuestra
familia nunca discutió en las fiestas
navideñas seguro que sí
pues algo parecido es lo que piensan en
el kremlin digamos que la familia sigue
siendo la familia
[Música]
de esta forma rusia intentado ser más
madre de rusia que nunca y ha reunido en
torno a la unión económica eurasiática a
cuatro antiguas repúblicas soviéticas
kazajistán bielorrusia kirguistán y
armenia
pero y qué pasa con el resto pues hay de
todo en primer lugar tenemos a lituania
letonia y estonia las tres repúblicas
bálticas son algo así como esos
parientes que un día emigraron y
hicieron dinero o viven bien y ya pues
no quieren saber absolutamente nada de
su vida anterior
luego en segundo lugar están tres de los
países que forman parte de la llamada
asociación oriental de la unión europea
estos son ucrania georgia y moldavia
tres países que tienen acuerdos de libre
comercio con el bloque europeo y que
sueñan o bueno al menos soñaban con
poder convertirse algún día en miembro
de pleno derecho
también en este mismo club encontramos a
azerbaiyán que es un importante socio
energético para europa y que tal y como
ya os contamos hace muy poquito tiempo
aquí un visual político mantiene una
especie de conflicto de guerra
permanente y contra armenia
[Música]
y en el caso de estos cuatro países
después nos encantaría seguir el ejemplo
de las repúblicas bálticas pero en
europa pues como quien oye llover
por último encontramos al resto de
países de esa central türkmenistán es el
pariente loco de la familia y tal y como
ya nos contó fonseca en este vídeo vive
un aislamiento internacional
prácticamente total
luego los dos que quedan uzbekistán y
tayikistán tienen un problema se llevan
fatal así que parece poco probable que
la unión económica eurasiática consiga
cerrar los tayikos después de noticias
como esta
uzbekistán se convertirá en observador
en la unión económica euroasiática
liderada por rusia el caso es que en
calidad de observador que viene a ser
una especie de socio de país que quiere
cooperar con la alianza
uzbekistán coincidirá con moldavia un
país que se ha cansado de esperar a
bruselas y mira de nuevo hacia moscú a
ver qué saca de jugar a los bandas
pero llegados a este punto la pregunta
es en qué consiste exactamente esto de
la unión económica eurasiática hasta qué
punto rusia mueve los hilos y lo que es
más importante puede llegar a
convertirse en una comunidad similar a
la unión europea
hoy emisor político vamos a dar
respuesta a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
un trauma de nacimiento
amigos la unión económica euroasiática
arrastra una especie de trauma un trauma
de nacimiento pensar una cosa cuantas
veces habéis escuchado que el eje
parís-berlín mueve la unión europea de
hecho ahí está el propio origen la unión
europea nació de la necesidad de los
países como alemania y francia- de
cooperar entre ellos para construir un
futuro compartido después de un siglo
atizándose de guerra tras guerra
sin embargo el punto de partida en el
espacio postsoviético es muy pero que
muy diferente completamente distinto
tres cuartas partes del territorio de la
antigua urss forman la actual federación
rusa y tan solo rusia tiene más
población que las catorce repúblicas
restantes de esta forma es evidente que
cualquier organización que trate de
montarse con estos nombres pues bailará
al son que le toquen el de moscú
[Música]
y claro como os podéis imaginar este
planteamiento asusta a las antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas los que mandan en
todos estos países lo que quieren es
seguir mandando no tener que volver a
recibir órdenes pero pues con un temor
que por cierto tiene mucho que ver con
el trauma de nacimiento que arrastra
esta organización amigos viajemos hasta
el 2004
[Aplausos]
la unión europea abrió en 2004 sus
puertas europa del este- una ampliación
que debilitó la posición geopolítica de
russian dos sentidos por un lado el
kremlin tuvo que presenciar la entrada
en la europea de las repúblicas bálticas
tres territorios integrados en el
antiguo unión soviética pero es que por
otro lado también entraban en la familia
europea polonia hungría república checa
y eslovaquia y pocos años después
bulgaria y rumanía un cambio de bando de
prácticamente todos los países que
formaban parte del pacto de varsovia
símbolo del poder hegemónico de la urss
sobre el bloque comunista
[Música]
pues exactamente en ese momento es
cuando arrancan los esfuerzos del
kremlin para crear una organización su
propia organización para tratar de
recomponer el espacio postsoviético
[Música]
y claro vamos a ver cuál era la segunda
república más importante del antiguo no
es soviética ucrania
así que en ese planteamiento ruso
elegimos que tendría que ser esa especie
de paris berlin capaz de liderar el
nuevo bloque de esa forma se reduciría
esa sensación de que lo que pretende de
moscú literalmente es engullir al resto
para ese sensato no creéis
moscú kiev al frente de un nuevo bloque
internacional pues amigos
un momento porque hay un problema la
población de ucrania nunca quiso saber
nada pero que nada de este proyecto y
ojo porque éste tira y afloja entre unos
intereses y otros ha causado ni más ni
menos que dos revoluciones en ucrania la
primera de ellas la revolución naranja
las elecciones presidenciales en ucrania
en 2004 enfrentaron al primer ministro
viktor yanúkovich procedente de las
regiones orientales de ucrania y
claramente prorruso contra el opositor
víctor yúschenko europeo ya favor de
ucrania entrase en la otan en un primer
momento se dio como ganador a yanukóvich
inmediatamente la oposición denunció el
fraude electoral y comenzaron las
fuertes protestas populares de la
revolución naranja al final la justicia
ordenó repetir las elecciones y se
impuso yúschenko
sin embargo ya os lo hemos dicho las
cosas en esta parte del mundo están casi
tan movidas como un juego de tronos la
coalición que apoyaba yúschenko se
rompió rápidamente y digamos que su
gobierno fue bastante decepcionante a
pesar incluso de que fue la época en la
que un cremiento a formar parte de la
asociación oriental de la unión europea
pero por lo demás pues prácticamente
ningún avance
de esta forma es como las elecciones de
2010 ganó por fin yanukóvich y ahora sí
con un progreso en kiev el kremlin
empezó a mover los hilos para impulsar
una organización regional
el primer paso fue poner en marcha una
unión aduanera entre rusia kazajistán y
bielorrusia pero el problema el problema
es que las cosas en ucrania no dejaron
de complicarse y de hecho todo se
precipitó cuando el presidente
yanukóvych quiso romper las
negociaciones para alcanzar un acuerdo
de asociación y de libre comercio con la
unión europea y tener así vía libre para
sumarse al bloque liderado por rusia
entonces entonces fue cuando estalló la
revolución de la humanidad y ya sabéis
lo que pasó ya en un kobe huyó a rusia
as
pero amigos esta vez el kremlin no se
quedó quieto
cuando finalice a braña y para todas
matrícula constitucional con el premio
de brasil de nuevo estuviera generar se
publicarán en total
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el caso es que bueno ya sabéis cómo
están las cosas en el este de ucrania
con guerrillas rebeldes apoyadas por
moscú y si puede que esto le supusiera
rusia empeora sus relaciones con la
unión europea pero putin mandó un
mensaje muy potente al resto de
repúblicas exsoviéticas o estáis conmigo
o ya sabéis lo que os puede pasar en
cualquier momento
de esta forma apenas dos meses más tarde
se firmó el tratado por el que nacía la
unión económica eurasiática atentos
[Música]
cinco países cinco objetivos amigos tras
esa especie de trauma de nacimiento que
arrastra la unión económica eurasiática
otro de los principales problemas que
afronta la organización es la falta de
un propósito común
[Música]
y es que veréis cada uno de los cinco
países que forman parte de la unión
tiene sus propios objetivos y créeme
creedme si os digo que pueden llegar a
ser muy pero que muy diferentes
por ejemplo el de rusia es el más
evidente la integración económica
regional se ha convertido en una especie
de fórmula para impulsar la prosperidad
de esta forma consigue un mercado más
amplio y más estable para sus propios
productos
además como venimos comentando lideran
una organización de este tipo en el
espacio postsoviético que es algo muy
útil para el kremlin en ese objetivo que
tienen de reforzar la posición global de
rusia la vuelta de la madre de rusia
bueno
nada de esto implica ningún tipo de
renacimiento de la univer soviética
sería ingenuo tratar de revivir y
regular algo que ha sido enviado a la
historia pero estos tiempos requieren de
una estrecha integración basada en
nuevos valores y una nueva base política
y económica sugerimos una asociación
supranacional poderosa capaz de
convertirse en uno de los polos en el
mundo moderno y servir como un puente
eficiente entre europa y la dinámica
región de asia y el pacífico
vladimir putin y ahora en todo este
juego el importante papel reservado en
principio ucrania ha recaído en
kazajistán
y es que cuando esta unión se puso en
marcha en 2015 kazajistán tenía un buen
motivo para actuar con cautela una
cuarta parte de la población del país es
de etnia rusa
y eso eso significa ni más ni menos que
el pretexto que putin utilizó para
reaccionar su primea ya sabéis eso de
proteger a los ciudadanos rusos y a las
personas que hablan ruso también podría
aplicarse allí
pero un momento por que kazajistán a
diferencia de ucrania también se guarda
más dos ases bajo la manga
en primer lugar era consciente de la
imperiosa necesidad rusa de liderar un
bloque regional tras sufrir las graves
sanciones de occidente por crimen
y luego en segundo lugar kazajistán
tiene alternativas a rusia lo que es
algo muy pero que muy importante y es
que veréis de la situación geográfica
china tiene fuertes inversiones en el
país y hoy por hoy es su principal socio
comercial
así que si bien creía en un incentivo
importante para llevarse bien con putin
digamos que casi estar tan poco serio
tan acorralada como para decirle que sí
a todo
y eso eso cambió la historia
las intenciones iniciales de rusia para
el espacio postsoviético eran establecer
una unión más integral que abarcará un
régimen monetario unificado así como la
integración política y de defensa este
plan más extenso fue rechazado por
kazajistán decidida a priorizar el
aspecto económico por ello bloqueó las
sugerencias rusas para dotar a la unión
económica euroasiática de competencias
en coordinación de política exterior
defensa fronteriza política de visados
atención médica o educación kazajistán
también rechazó la pretensión rusa de
establecer un parlamento euroasiático y
dejó claro que no cedería a una pizca de
soberanía al unirse a la unión
cinco años cinco años han pasado desde
que el presidente nazarbáyev fijó la
posición kazaja ante esta unión y su
sucesor el presidente toca y lo tiene
igual de claro la opción económica
euroasiática es un proyecto económico
sin una dimensión política es una
asociación de naciones soberanas cuyo
enfoque es mejorar el ambiente para las
empresas y la inversión y eliminar las
barreras al comercio tanto dentro de los
países miembros como de sus socios
externos casi ni omar toca jeff
presidente de kazajistán por su parte
rusia cristian y armenia los otros tres
miembros también tienen sus propios
motivos para formar parte de esta
organización y es que a diferencia de
kazajistán no son ricos en recursos
naturales así que las promesas rusas de
petróleo y gas a precio de amigo han
sido un buen reclamo para atraerlos
es decir que con ofrecerles recursos
energéticos más baratos un mercado mayor
para vender su maquinaria pesada y
mantener la cooperación rusa pues no ha
necesitado más motivos para integrarse
[Música]
fijaos belorrusia lleva bajo la órbita
de moscú prácticamente desde su
independencia incluso tal y como os
comentamos existe un plan para integrar
ambos países
[Música]
luego por su parte equidistante cuya
economía vive de exportar productos
chinos ya había visto desde un principio
que la unión aduanera que se había
formado limitaba sus posibilidades así
que entró la unión euroasiática sin
muchos problemas claro que aquí rusia
también supo cómo convencer a rusia
asignar a 1.200 millones de dólares para
ayudar a kirguistán a unirse a la unión
aduanera y por ultimo armenia quiso
reforzar su posición ante el conflicto
que mantiene con su vecino hacer bellas
ambos países son socios militares de
rusia y armenia trato de decantar la
balanza reforzando sus lazos con el
kremlin eso sí de momento lo cierto es
que la cosa no ha funcionado
bien el caso es que hasta ahora hemos
visto cómo surgió esta unión económica y
también qué motivó a sus cinco
integrantes a unirse a la organización
pero seguro seguro que llegados a este
punto muchos os estaréis preguntando
vale muy bien enrique pero después de
cinco años de funcionamiento qué
demonios han conseguido que el futuro
les espera pues atentos
moscú sigue lejos de bruselas
amigo si lo bien económica eurasiática
quería parecerse en algo a la unión
solid tica de 1991 digamos que ya lo ha
conseguido funcionan igual de mal
tras 5 años de existencia el sentimiento
generalizado es que esta organización
está lejos muy lejos de cumplir con las
expectativas fijadas y la pregunta es a
qué se debe esto
pues sobre todo a que no pasa de ser una
organización entre países que ya
comercian entre sí y lo que es peor
entre economías que compiten entre sí en
muchos niveles de producción
además el peso de rusia de esta peculiar
unión conlleva un problema adicional
fijaos
si la economía rusa estornuda la unión
euroasiática se resfría a lo bestia
cuando se puso en marcha en 2011 la
unión aduanera original viento soplaba a
favor y el precio del petróleo era alto
las economías rusos y kazajas crecían y
bielorrusia también se beneficiaba pero
cuando la unión económica euroasiática
comenzó a funcionar en 2015 rusia estaba
ya en crisis tras la caída del precio
del petróleo y las acciones de occidente
por la anexión de crimea una crisis de
la que todavía no se ha recuperado
desde entonces la economía rusa sigue
sin recuperarse del todo y lo que menos
le interesa de llenar sus mercados con
los productos de sus socios de la unión
económica eurasiática
y esto esto es algo que tiene
consecuencias para el resto de miembros
ya que el comercio con rusia supone ni
más ni menos que el 96 por ciento del
comercio total dentro de la unión
euroasiática
vamos que más que una unión de países es
una unión de países para comerciar con
rusia
[Música]
por ejemplo tal y como podéis ver para
bielorrusia el comercio con rusia supone
prácticamente la mitad de todo su
comercio exterior y para el resto de
miembros la situación no es muy
diferente
[Música]
sin embargo a diferencia de ellos para
reducir este comercio apenas representa
el 8 el 8% de su cartera comercial es
decir que desde el punto de vista
económico pues para moscú esta alianza
no es algo tan importante
además la idea de tener un mercado común
está lejos de alcanzarse todavía hay
muchos sectores protegidos que quedan
fuera de la unión económica e incluso en
sectores en los que se supone que no hay
barreras los países en no pocas
ocasiones obstaculizan el comercio para
defender a sus productores nacionales
alegando motivos de todo tipo desde los
administrativos hasta los técnicos como
pueden ser los controles sanitarios y
veterinarios
vale es algo que están tratando de
solucionar pero aún queda mucho por
hacer a la hora de la verdad las cosas
van muy pero que muy despacio
sin ir más lejos la creación del mercado
eléctrico común se ha pospuesto hasta al
menos el 2025
para ese mismo año también está previsto
un mercado único para el petróleo y el
gas natural pero la pregunta es llegar a
ese momento
pues no lo sabemos pero lo que está
claro es que el hecho de que a rusia no
le interese mucho nos hace sospechar que
hoy por hoy los interrogantes son
mayores que las respuestas
y que porque no le interesa rusia pues
porque la política energética es un
activo esencial en la política exterior
de moscú y si en la política exterior no
se hace tanto negocios como política con
sus recursos naturales un ejemplo como
el gobierno de armenia no le gusta mucho
a putin el año pasado le subió el precio
del gas en un 10 por ciento y ya os
contamos aquí en visual político en un
vídeo que hicimos en febrero como rusia
utiliza el petróleo para presionar a
bielorrusia en aras de impulsar la unión
de ambos países pero ahora bien no todo
son malas noticias lo cierto es que la
unión económica energética también ha
tenido aspectos positivos por ejemplo la
libre circulación de trabajadores ha
aliviado la situación interna de armenia
y crystal ya que su población sin
trabajo tiene ahora más facilidades pues
para marcharse a rusia a buscarse la
vida y este cambio regulatorio ha sido
beneficioso para todos
por un lado con una población más
envejecida rusia obtiene mano de obra y
por otro los migrantes de armen existan
envían desde rusia cada año a casa miles
y miles de millones de dólares
[Música]
también en el lado positivo encontramos
la firma de acuerdos de libre comercio
lo han hecho por ejemplo con países como
egipto serbia vietnam y singapur o
incluso con china país con el que han
firmado un acuerdo de cooperación
comercial
y ojo porque china no es la única gran
potencia con la que han estrechado lazos
fijaos el acuerdo de libre comercio
entre irán y la unión económica euro es
ética entrará en vigor en dos o tres
años desde luego esta política de
fronteras abiertas del punto de vista
comercial podría ser la tabla de
salvación para una organización que
hasta ahora ha sido cómo decirlo
intrascendente en fin llegados a este
punto la pregunta es qué futuro le
augura es a la unión económica
eurasiática podrá llegar a consolidarse
realmente como una unión y fortalecer la
integración económica e incluso política
de sus países miembros será una
herramienta para el progreso o
simplemente anclar a el poder y la
influencia de rusia amigos dejamos
nuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
ya sabéis si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like suscribiros abisal polític si
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]